لقد قلتم أن هذا يوضح
الثقة التي يتمتع بها كل من البلدين ، الإمارات العربية المتحدة
وإيطاليا في نهجهما للتغلب على
الوباء ، فقط خذنا من خلال كيفية حدوث ذلك
بشكل جيد ، لقد أجرينا سلسلة من المكالمات الجماعية
الأسبوع الماضي
مع إدارة العديد من
المطارات
الإيطالية وواحد  الشيء الذي كان واضحًا
منذ البداية
هو أننا كنا متفقين تمامًا مع
رغبتنا في بدء
السفر وبالطبع مع بدء
فصل الصيف في نصف
الكرة الشمالي ، بالطبع يصبح
الجو حارًا للغاية هنا في الإمارات العربية المتحدة
وفي عام 2019 شيء مثل 660
حدثت 000 رحلة من نقطة إلى نقطة
بين إيطاليا والإمارات العربية
المتحدة وأكثر من 2.2 مليون رحلة عبور ومن
نقطة إلى نقطة
بين البلدين ، لذا
فهو تطور مهم
للغاية ويسعدني جدًا
أننا أه نحتفل بالإيطالية
اليوم الوطني غدًا
مع بدء الخدمات في ميلانو مالبينسا
روما لـ macchino ثم في يوليو إلى
البندقية ،
إنه إجراء بسيط لديك للتو
اختبار pcr قبل الانضمام إلى fl  ight في
دبي أو أبو ظبي
ثم عند الوصول إلى إيطاليا ، هناك
اختبار مستضد سريع جدًا عند الوصول ولأي
سبب من أسباب السفر ، فأنت على ما يرام للذهاب والتجول
حول تلك المواقع الرائعة في جميع أنحاء
إيطاليا جيدًا ، أحد الأسئلة الكبيرة المتبقية
هو متى تكون الإمارات العربية المتحدة
قد يتم حذفه من القائمة الحمراء للمملكة المتحدة
للبلدان المحظورة للسفر الدولي
، المملكة المتحدة
سوق ضخم للمسافرين إلى
دبي
أم التحديث القادم لنظام إشارات المرور
الخاص بها هو الخميس هذا الأسبوع ، هل لديك
أي ثقة
في أن المملكة المتحدة ستزيل الإمارات العربية المتحدة  تلك القائمة الحمراء
أعتقد أن المشكلة بالطبع هي أن
الوضع في المملكة المتحدة لا يبدو
رائعًا ، لقد كانوا يقومون بعمل
جيد في احتواء انتشار kobit
19 ولكن بالطبع في الآونة الأخيرة
يبدو أن هذا الموقف أكثر
صعوبة
لذلك لست متأكدًا من ذلك  ستغير المملكة المتحدة
وضع دولة الإمارات العربية المتحدة ، من
الواضح أننا نتوقع حدوث شيء ما
في مرحلة ما في المستقبل ،
لكنني أعتقد في الوقت الحالي أن
الممر الذي اتفقنا عليه مع
تُعد إيطاليا خطوة إيجابية
للغاية وإذا ظهرت خطوات أخرى ربما مع
الاتحاد الأوروبي
ككل والولايات المتحدة خلال
الأسابيع القليلة المقبلة ، فربما يمنح ذلك حكومة
المملكة المتحدة
الشجاعة والقناعة
للسماح فعليًا بإعادة تشغيل الرحلات الجوية
بين الإمارات العربية المتحدة والولايات المتحدة الأمريكية.  المملكة المتحدة
كما قلت ، بيكي ، المملكة المتحدة هي
سوق مهم للغاية حيث لندن هي أكبر
طريق للسفر الجوي بين الإمارات العربية
المتحدة والمملكة المتحدة ،
لذا فنحن جميعًا حريصون جدًا على بدء هذه
المناقشات
[موسيقى]
تتحدث عن الاتحاد الأوروبي والولايات المتحدة
لقد كنت تحث الدول الأخرى على أن
تحذو حذو الإماراتيين والإماراتيين في
جمع ممر السفر هذا معًا ، فمن
تتوقع أن يكون بولس القادم
جيدًا ، أعتقد أن الأخبار المشجعة
من الإمارات هي أنهم يتحركون
على مستوى الإمارات العربية المتحدة  نظام جواز سفر اللقاح
الذي أعتقد أنه من المحتمل أن يكون الحل طويل الأمد
لفتح ممرات السفر مرة
أخرى وإذا كان هذا هو الحال ، فسيتم السماح لأولئك الذين
تم
تلقيحهم باللقاحات المعتمدة
لأوروبا  د لدخول
دول الاتحاد الأوروبي وأنا أعلم أن هناك نظامًا
مشابهًا قيد التنفيذ في الولايات المتحدة
ويجب أن تمكن هذه الأنظمة الرقمية
الأشخاص من السفر
دون مواجهة أي مشاكل في
المطار بسبب أعمال اختبار الدورة التدريبية
ولكنها تتطلب
قدرًا كبيرًا جدًا من السعة للاختبار
في  مطار الوصول ، لا يتطلب
نظام جواز سفر اللقاح
فحصًا ماديًا ، لذا فهو
وسيلة أكثر فاعلية للسفر
، وإذا كنا سننتقل إلى
التنقل الشخصي ، فقد فقدنا جميعًا
منذ أكثر من عام
الآن جواز سفر اللقاح في  وجهة نظري هي
الطريقة الوحيدة للوصول إلى هناك